hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm going
to be checking out a trailer trailer I
don't think this is an actual trailer
for a movie I think it's just the
trailer they cut together not a hand job
cabin the official HD trailer featuring
Owen Benjamin cool what this is awesome
the five cloud service and the service
[Music]
okay free boner pills party stop it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
indeed ankylosing vanishes victim freak
OTP [ __ ] accident when her hand job
hand slips causing it to strike her own
face and tumble out of a window toward
death
[Music]
neither hands and life sometimes things
are far worse than death and normally
when someone receives and they just hate
it in this place they die on the inside
and it's all her fault
there's something evil in this place
with calloused hands and strong wrists
and solely one thing assert she's the
only one who comes in this cab she comes
[Music]
Wow dude that was like hilarious and
scary as [ __ ] you say you talk like such
a ridiculous it's kind of like watching
a rack a rack a video where you're like
the context of it is so funny with the
executions kind of you know terrifying
to look at cuz the ghost chick looks
scary the [ __ ] ghost looks scary I
mean I mean I don't know what I would do
if she was jerking me like when I go
through it I couldn't even get a boner
that's a situation that I often think
about even before I saw this trailer
like if a ghost were to jerk me off like
a demonic looking insidious creature or
to jerk me off would I be able to get
into it
truth is I don't know gotta wait til the
moment happens but when it does you'll
get a reaction of that this is a great
spoof like a parody of the you know
going to the cabin kind of [ __ ] and it's
a ridiculous concept but like I keep
saying it was kind of scary the way it
came across like it looks haunting it
looks terrifying and it looks like
honestly I know this is just the tre I
don't know if they're trying to get a
feature film actually made out of this
but the skit of this is great I love
horror comedies that have all kinds of
horror genres horror comedies are my
favorite I was watching Shaun of the
Dead the other day we gonna do a review
for it and post it on this channel but I
was watching Shaun of the Dead the other
day and that is one of my favorite films
of all time one of my favorite horror
movies of all time and it's so [ __ ]
funny at the same time but there's
always a fear element going on I love
that and same thing with this was like
it's scary but it's funny it's a great
blend of the two I love the look of it
like they they ex they shot it like a
horror film they went all out with
really capturing it they didn't try to
shoot it like a comedy which is what I
really like because it's the fact that
they committed so much to the horror of
this ridiculous con
but why it works so much anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you can subscribe to
the Rio rejects and become a rejected a
keeper gang and say that and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine in periscope I want to give a shout
out
Julian Trevino hey guys I've been
watching your videos for a while now I
have a YouTube channel and my channel
name is mr. cinnamon biscuit I do comedy
sketches vlogs reactions what are you
copying my channel and gaming I've only
done one gaming video so let you get
away with that I've ever been working on
a movie for a while now and I would like
to begin give me a shout-out thanks for
all the joy the comedy guys brought into
my life mr. cinnamon biscuit let's see
what you look like okay so this is the
only photo you have yourself on Facebook
listen dude I'm sorry but this might be
just because I just watched the trailer
but I feel like you would you know
molest me with a [ __ ] just saying you
know like I've always wondered that like
what if I got molested but I got turned
on while being molested I know this
isn't like the kind of humor I usually
go down I don't really cover like you
know sexual assault jokes but you know
I'm looking at you and I'm thinking hey
if this guy gave me a [ __ ] without my
consent
I might still pop a boner and come so
you should check out his channel mr.
cinnamon biscuit